The shocking truth is that the squares marked A and B are actually the same
shade of gray. If you don't believe it, here's a bit of proof. An image where
two vertical bands with the same shade of gray are overlaid on the image. So,
you can see here and here that these gray bars, they're all the same intensity.
And that they're also the same intensity as this A and this B square. So, these
are all the same gray, believe it or not. If you still don't believe it, you can
print out the original image and cut out squares A and B and hold them up next
to each other. See the additional course materials for where to get these
images. As professor Adelson notes, this illusion proves that the visual system
is not a very good light meter, but that's not its purpose. Our visual system
tries to compensate for shadows and other distractions so that we can properly
perceive the nature of the objects in view.